hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day
capitalism was built on Stolen land
stolen labor and stolen resources and a
check today could not
um undo the cumulative impact of
generations of that stolen wealth in all
of those categories and so I think it
has to come in the form of land labor
and resources in an ongoing fashion and
there are structures that we have that
could be flipped to to begin to do that
we just that reparations
um in fact my opponent here mentioned
Five Points in the corridor and what has
happened to our businesses there
part of what has catalyzed that
exponential decimation of black
businesses is the Five Points bid the
business Improvement District
which further steals from the community
through taxation and I think there's a
model that could be redistributed
instead of a bid collecting extra
taxation From the Block and ground
businesses that are struggling you could
be collecting those extra taxes from
Whiteland businesses all over the city
and redistributing them to black and
brown owned businesses who are not
marketed or who are simply just black or
brown owned and that's one way to give
back in the business form fashion I
think when we talk about
um
resources being returned this is where
consumer owned or municipally owned
resources are important because we are
locked out of owning our control or over
our basic needs like
um water or utilities or any of those
things there is a way for us to change
that structure and put black and brown
people in ownership positions over our
basic needs I also really want to point
out that the basic income project could
be if it were focused an important way
to return a check to an individual in an
ongoing fashion but in its current
format is not reparations or not close
to regulations one it doesn't focus on
black and brown people two what they are
experimenting with is unhoused people
and it's not a livable or prosperous
wage it is a welfare wage and we know
how that has worked but those types of
checks have not served us well and we
need to go far beyond
welfare wages and go to prosperous wages
because we don't want to just survive
anymore in recreational goal should not
be survival it should be preparing the
harm which is entire economy
thank you